sometimes I get I'll get like Irish
eyebrow right I mean right gonna pull
out what's the Irish eyebrow that's when
it gets like those Irish righties to get
those eyebrows yeah and you look like
some old Irish right if you hold a stand
to it why what do you think Brooklyn
thinks of you saying that even tweeze
your eyebrows yeah that's bad but the
new Brooklyn probably no they love the
old guys I used to like Carla no tweeze
his eyebrows I can't watch your stuff
yeah a little metrosexual back in the
day now I'm not so much I mean you're
not will be the judge of that
what's up everybody I'm Krista Stefano
aka Krissy nipples and I'm here with
Colin Quinn from Brooklyn New York that
was your problem what's the stupidest
thing your mom ever made you where she
didn't make me wear a chair she bought
me I had an Australian hat right so it
was almost like a half a pimp hat yeah
from the early 70s my hips superfly nice
and hair for the Australian like outback
hat right and the mistake she made was
to let me wear it to school there's an
you were target yeah you got beat up -
my mother bought me a neon green swim
cap with flowers on the side by the ears
I wore that thing Johnny's and groaning
from Middle Village you hit me in the
face with a wiffle ball bat that was
like a nice swim cap flower face Oh what
happens you grow up in Brooklyn Queens I
get dropped
he's a stupid question what's the last
dream you had huh
what's the last comment by the way hon
beans hop I'm not gonna tell the last
Jew I really had I'll take it a clean
one no I'm trying to think what Celeste
I'm at a good dream what happened good
yeah it's gotta be the sex or murder or
else we don't want to hear it I always
have um a dream that some secret agency
it's like you know like they're knocking
on my mother's window right like we need
to see your son the door open but the
door opened it's got like this green
light coming out right and they what
they always want to ask me questions
about aliens it's like an I'm dumb again
it's either that or a secret they wanted
you to reveal something about yourself
that you're not comfortable revealing
yet well should I just do it in a
society it's why I'm gay you other
wanted you know it's stupid question
when you were kid will you more scared
of cooties or ghosts I was scared of
ghosts for a minute right I was kidding
ghosts I'm still scared of ghosts people
burn what's better get a house my
mother's I know you got to buy a house
you got a family I was like I need to
live in a studio apartment I need to
open the door and visually scan the room
because the guess where guess where the
ghosts and the murderers are on any
floor this oh you're right I've slept
since I was a child I've slept with
either a giant butcher knife or an ax
for many years a little mini hand ax
under my pillow when next to my neck
sleepers in the little cut on the bed
right there like there I sleep like that
and I my hands usually on it with a axe
yep still to this day no now I have an
Afghani knife to take a killing knife no
I have a granola Gator doing told me
there's a couple of bodies on it too
really that's what I have right now the
Afghani knife in your bed yeah Wow
I dare somebody to try to rob Europe oh
my god they're gonna surprise it in life
all right calm you have a good time on
the show I did thanks for being here and
I'll give you a stupid gift now all
right you know a big history guy I'm a
big history guy I thought why not
colonial hats are really now colonial
they kind of look like a corner hat it's
like a colonial stripper would wear yeah
you think we'd be good soldiers in the
Revolutionary War I would run you have
no choice you know would you run to
there's no way to run to this right here
your neighborhood all the battles are
happening right there the whole British
Army gets where they entered the United
States or the 13 colonies this was a
call back then
Denis Ferry in Bay Ridge Brooklyn take
my hat off to you the British you get a
bad rap we should have kept you in
charge in this country yeah but thank
you for Adele it's not a it's not a
popular these gifts really stunk yeah I
know I'm being serious
I should have think more carefully I
mean I got this at the 99-cent store
you're not grateful it's what I like to
do to your face right there
[Laughter]